political power without development
is not real power
you can have all the hot air you want
but if you don't have the balloon the
ropes and the basket
you can't
turn it into a hot air balloon and take
flight it just won't happen
[Music]
i'm still here that's right living
inside this tent for 100 days from
november the 20th to february 28th
bringing to you issues and awareness as
it relates to gun violence in the city
of chicago on the south side on this
block called oh block where we're trying
to raise as much money as we possibly
can to build a community center it's
called oh block because it's named after
a young man named od perry who was shot
and killed the gangs picked up the o in
his name and started calling it o block
well we decided we're going to keep the
o but we're going to call it opportunity
block i want to thank fox network for
giving me the opportunity to bring to
you rooftop revelations every single day
i want to share with you my thoughts my
opinions my own viewpoints
so today i want to share with you this
one of the biggest ideological battles
in the black community has been whether
to pursue political power or development
w.e.b du bois was of the mind that we
should pursue political power
while booker t washington believed in
development
one power one development i can
understand both arguments
sometimes context is necessary however
during the voices time blacks had very
little political power and there were
laws on the books that legalized
segregation and other racial horrors we
had to fight politically to change the
opinion of america and
its politicians it was a fight that we
had to do
while this was going
blacks never abandoned development many
of us migrated from the south to the
north to pursue
better opportunities we created jazz we
wrote some of the best books in america
we invented an untold number of
inventions we transformed sports
forever
our influence went beyond america
to the rest
of the world however in the last 60
years or so it seems that
we've come to rely on political power
than development
our black leaders like al sharpton and
jesse jackson have
banked on this political power
and there's not much to show for it
we've had black mayors including in this
city
and it's not making
a lot of difference
we've had a black president from
here in chicago and sorry to say that
didn't make much difference for us as
well
and i'm not here to bash political power
at all i think we need it but it seems
to have come at the expense of
development
and that is the real crime here
our so-called political litters
point the finger at everything but black
accountability and if they do look at
black accountability it is not with the
seriousness it's more like
lip service
political power without development
is not real power
you can have all the hot air you want
but if you don't have the balloon the
ropes and the basket
you can't
turn it into a hot air balloon and take
flight it just won't happen
this is why i've made my mission to
focus on development development
development
we cannot politic our way out of this
mess
but we certainly can develop our way out
of it
all this political power in the last 60
70 years has left us with crime
bad schools
lack of businesses
and so many other things
development is the key here
see development is something that takes
place within a person's soul
as they develop and acquire skills they
start to become
somebodies they start to believe in
themselves they they come alive they
become a part of the community and
an asset to the community they they
might even become politicians wiser
politicians we hope
right now
in this very moment
in america
development is what is most needed it is
the way upward
and that's what we do every day with our
church and with project hood
that's why
i believe
and that's why i'm on this roof god
bless you and god bless america
you